stylish  efficient and automated  these could be the words we use to  describe the london underground in the  not so distant future  transport for london who run the tube as  it's more locally known says the new  walk through carriages will create vital  space for passengers at peak times  and london's up against it the city's  population is expected to rise from  around 8.4 million people today to 10  million by 2030.  one line the new trains will join could  see an extra 19 000 passengers carried  every hour  several engineering firms have been  shortlisted for the deal that could be  worth two and a half billion pounds for  250 trains when they do eventually join  london's underground network next decade  they'll be in service for 40 years  that's why they'll come with the  capability to run without a driver  although that's not likely to happen for  a few years yet  but the feature most londoners will look  forward to  they come with aircon  tom gibson bloomberg